fini les clubs et les bals place au
ballon de football sur les parcours de
golf
inventée aux pays-bas en 2009 le foot
golf se développe en france on compte
aujourd'hui cinq mille licenciés et
10000 pratiquants chaque année le fou de
golf en fait c'est comme son nom
l'indiqué du golfe mais avec un ballon
de foot donc globalement la discipline
c'est vraiment un parcours de golf
on a un point et on a en a un trou dans
lequel mettre le ballon en moins de
coups possible et donc ça se joue en
parcours de 18 trous
au niveau des compétitions et on a
exactement le même vocabulaire que le
golf à savoir là on a des par 3 par
quatre par 5 on va faire des birdy
déboguer départ pas besoin d'être
professionnel pour remplir ses 18 trous
une bonne technique avec le ballon un
oeil aiguisé de golfeurs et le tour est
joué
un mélange qui plaît à ses adhérents
après mois avec les pentes
j'arrive à voir c'est ce que recherchent
c'est un golfeur mais je pense que oui
il faudra des notions de golf de foot et
surtout beaucoup de mental je pense que
ça joue beaucoup
c'est un sport on est face à soi même on
peut en vouloir à personne
une dizaine de kilomètres par parcours
le plein air un ballon puisque je suis
un ancien footeux et un ancien golfeur
enfin voilà bande de potes un club
extraordinaire donc tous les éléments
sont réunis pour pour cette activité
après l'escale parisienne l'afutt gold
cup continue son tour de la france
trente six étapes sont au programme
avant la grande finale prévue à la fin
de l'année